and he made a joke about trayvon martin
the kid who was murdered
and he said um uh maybe you wouldn't
have gotten murdered if you had a job
and it's like what the [ __ ]
you know like what the [ __ ] were you
thinking right
but they got burned because they they
kind of they laughed at the joke
it doesn't help that they're white yeah
yeah you know what i'm saying
and so they put out a public apology
video and you guys know who they are
they're stephen nicky so stephen nicki
put out a public apology video
the first one that they did wasn't that
great um i don't think they awarded it
very well i think they got scared
and so they wanted to put out a quick
apology video but they did a second one
which was a lot better and they
apologized for it yeah they apologized
what
what how it hurt the community
specifically in these times right now
and a lot of people are asking me in
five four three
two one what's up everybody welcome to
an episode of the genius brain podcast
we have edric in the house also known as
ed2
yes sir people like you on here man they
say your voice is very soothing
so let me just do like a dedicated like
help you sleep at night type thing oh
you should do
you know i've been trying to get this
other dude his name is jeremy he has a
very
deep bassy voice i was telling him he
should just do a podcast or not even a
podcast where he just reads like
nighttime stories
because i would listen to that [ __ ] yeah
no i mean um when i was uh
like in high school and like college um
yeah girls used to tell me like dude you
should be a late night radio
host you know like i could fall asleep
to your voice
and i didn't know like how to take that
i was like are you saying i'm sound
boring
or you know you i got a soothing voice
or what but um
yeah they're like yeah you should be a
late night radio host you know like
i could imagine listening to you late at
night and then just falling asleep to it
you know it's weird like on before i had
this podcast and
actually not even just this podcast i
don't think a lot of people know what
their voice sounds like
yeah and then um you don't know a lot of
the mannerisms you for sure
for sure i figured out when i was doing
this podcast and every time that i had
coffee before i shot this yeah
i would speak so [ __ ] fast i had no
idea
i would listen to this podcast and i
didn't know what the [ __ ] i was saying
yeah but it's interesting i think
that a lot of people because they've
heard me speak for so long they pick up
on it really quick
because in my head it sounds very
coherent right but then when i'm
listening to myself sometimes i'm like
bro i don't know what you're saying man
and what's uh what's the there's a term
for that no like when you listen back to
yourself for the first time isn't there
a word for that
i don't know but i know that people get
people don't like the sound of their
voices right and what i heard was that
when you speak it reverberates through
your skull or whatever and then whatever
you hear from that out is a
augmented version with somebody else's
yeah right yeah no
that when i uh first started doing music
and i recorded for the first time
i was like yo that's how i [ __ ] sound
like
i'm like dude i [ __ ] hate my voice
yeah yeah yeah yeah i gotta do something
i gotta get like the game's raspiness or
something you know
um i it it took me a while man just to
kind of get over that part um
i would like record tracks and then i'd
listen back and i'm like
dude i don't like the way i sound like i
it's like that's your voice though and
i'm like
well i got to do something about it
because if that's how i sound like i i
don't i don't want to hear myself
so why would anybody else want to hear
me that's the same thing when i when i
record
uh you know when me and z do music yeah
right and then i'm trying to sound a
certain way and it sounds way better in
my head for sure it does
and then when you hear the raw vocals
i'm like what the [ __ ] is that dude
10 out of 10 that's how it always is
it's like you recite
you know what you got written down and
then like you're like oh i'm at a place
now where
where it's it's great you know like i'm
ready to record this and you record it
and it throws you off your eggs you're
like [ __ ] man that's not what was in my
head when i was reciting it i think the
hardest part for a lot of like people
who want to be
uh like young musicians out there right
now i think like music is so accessible
you have you get to
kind of uh sample a lot of different
things for sure i think that's why
stylistically when it comes to seeing
i'm seeing a lot of different stuff
yeah but at the same time one of the
things that i see a lot that i get
really disappointed in
is how everybody tries to sound the same
yeah because you know back in the day
right we're talking about
uh snoop sounds like snoop right hello
cool j sounds like ello cool j dr dre
sounds like dr dre uh biggie sounds like
biggie tupac sounds like tupac right
but i feel like a lot of the stuff when
i look at the top hits on spotify i
don't know who a lot of these artists
are
yeah right so for example who's a couple
of people that passed away uh
that juice world kid right so juice
world and
everybody that's in his division of
hip-hop they i can't tell the difference
between them yeah i'm not saying their
music is bad but what i'm saying is like
you guys swagger jack somebody [ __ ] and
then you didn't make
enough uh changes to make it your own
sound yeah so when you hear that kid
juice world or right here i don't know
like
[ __ ] who's that one is he white uh i
think he's like mixed but he looks
really white
who uh he was that one kid that made uh
he did like [ __ ] [ __ ] eyes in one
of his
music videos he got really he got oh
[ __ ] i don't know yeah
that that does uh sound familiar with
the [ __ ] i think he did he he had a
collab with uh
kanye and they were wearing those that
felt oh yeah yeah uh
uh what's that kid's name i don't listen
to his music so
exactly yeah yeah you guys know who the
[ __ ] we're talking about right but i
forgot what then i confused his stuff
with like little uzi verb i don't know
the damn difference
yeah and i think like the hard part is
especially and this is the same thing
for people who sing
they all kind of start to sound exactly
the same and i think like the hard part
is for
certain musicians especially when it
comes to singers is that sometimes
people don't work with the voice that
they have and they try to steal a voice
that somebody else has right
right and you know i mean that's the
thing though like when you're first
starting out
in my opinion anyway like the best is to
emulate the greats right because
they're great for a reason um and their
music is timeless for a reason so you
start emulating them to kind of start
discovering yourself but
that's the point you got to take that
next step to discover your own style
through that
you know um but then when it just
becomes like
pure emulation um then there's no
originality there's no artistry in it
and like that's the thing man um some
people might think i'm a hater for it
but
i just think today's music for the most
part is
is not that timeless you know yeah and
like you said
i look at the the top hits like top
singles top artists
i don't know like 90 of who the [ __ ]
these artists are because i don't even
bother to listen to their [ __ ] you know
yeah i've i've heard kind of like what's
popular out there without knowing who
the artist is and it's enough for me to
not want to look into who the artist is
yeah you know
uh whereas for us like growing up in the
golden era of hip-hop
and r b like those those
jams and those artists are still
relevant today right
they're still very well respected the
music today is still considered hits
but then i don't know like 20 years from
now
if music coming out of 2020 2019 2018 is
is going to be considered timeless you
know
yeah i that's the sometimes i wonder
it's like am i just [ __ ] old
am i just one of those like i questioned
that too you know because i i don't want
to sound like a hater either right
because it's not like i don't enjoy that
music when it plays right it's like oh
this is [ __ ] dope like i [ __ ] with it
yeah
but can i recite the lyrics no can i
recognize it from another song not
really you know what i mean and i don't
know if i'd be listening that [ __ ] later
on because it's not like i don't [ __ ]
with these artists yeah i think like the
music is dope
but in in terms of the conversation of
it being timeless
that's where i don't know if it's
timeless i i if i were to bet my money
on it i would say
it wouldn't be timeless it's just
honestly it's relevant to right now
and that that's all it's going to be and
you know for me the only reason why i
recognize these songs
is because i recognize i don't like that
song
i don't like that song you know that's
how i remember not because oh [ __ ]
i remember this jam because it was dope
i don't even know who the artist is but
i thought it was a dope jam
um nah it's like dude i i don't like
this song so i want to [ __ ] turn this
song off right now
um i think one of the things that i
always like to reference to is uh
was it the breakfast club i think i
think it was the breakfast club with uh
with uh jay-z when jay-z came on yeah
and he was talking about the evolution
of music and
how uh i forgot who said this but
somebody was like don't you think
there's uh
there's no good music out there he goes
no i think there's a lot of great music
out there
it's just that uh you just got to really
listen for it right you know so
that's and then he also kind of said
something very poignant which i which i
100 agree
and he's talking about how how we kind
of
digest music nowadays is too fast we're
too quick to say
an album is the greatest of all time
we're quick to say the track is like the
best [ __ ] track out there
and we never really sit with music
because of how uh music was received
who the critics were because everybody
can be a critic now including me like i
can be a critic and so
after i listened to that interview i
went back and i listened to some of the
albums that i didn't like from artists
that i really liked
and i started listening albums once
again like we used to back in the day
yeah
from uh front to end right and when you
listen to
an album from front to end sonically it
just sounds so much better yeah but
we're picking and choosing certain
tracks because we feel like we vibe with
it real quick
but we're not really thinking about what
the artist did to create that album as a
whole
yeah yeah i mean and that's the thing is
that nowadays
we're talking about instant
gratification mass consumption
right so nobody really has the
um like attention capacity or or even
the desire to sit there and like really
treat an album as an experience like
it's a movie or something
you know and and there are definitely
artists who are still trying to do that
in in current time and like one of the
most
i guess notable artists would be kanye
you know he still does try to
sometimes make an experience out of his
album from start to finish
but nowadays it's all about single i
mean that's what it's been
singles you know ever since the shift
happened to digital it's really been
about singles and it's a singles market
nobody's really caring about
uh trying to sell full albums they want
to sell songs i mean
it's the way that everything kind of
evolved because nobody really wants to
wait for art anymore
for sure they want to have it now and if
they don't have it now they move on to
the next position which is kind of sad
because we're talking about
like it's hard to say who's really a fan
of something now right because
i feel like for people that i'm a fan of
whether you release something
a year from now two three four five six
seven yeah i'm still
gonna be waiting for that [ __ ] right
like for example
uh because i [ __ ] with i don't know uh
like j cole j cole could take a hiatus
for two three years
yeah and when this album drops i'm i'm
the first one to cop it right
easy [ __ ] same thing with like kendrick
uh my current favorite artist is this
dude from that show
uh from that one uh hip-hop show that
was on netflix with like ti and
everybody uh-huh
a d smoke okay no i have to have the
smoke is [ __ ] fire dude like he
he's uh from l.a straight out of compton
and this dude
is i'm sorry not cop sorry inglewood
okay he wraps inglewood really hard
and uh he's like one of those people he
when you first listen to him he kind of
sounds
like kendrick he has that kendrick vibe
right obviously they're both from l.a
kind of from the
from similar neck of the woods so they
kind of have a similar style but when
you listen to them really
they sound very sonically different yeah
but if you if you love
like kendrick you love j cole you'll
[ __ ] love these smokes i'll check him
out and i feel like he makes a lot of
timeless music like i've
i've never had a new artist come out
where i played him so
repetitively constantly i love your [ __ ]
yeah yeah and but i mean the thing is
that's not to take away from like the
artistry
of current music too um because at the
end of the day
art music is subjective right there's
it's gonna be somebody's cup of tea and
it's somebody else it's they're gonna be
like that's garbage um so
i don't ever disrespect like somebody's
artistry
just because i don't like it doesn't
mean that it's trash it just means like
that it doesn't resonate with me for
whatever reason you know
um but at the same time if i
was trying to create that type of music
i probably couldn't do it yeah and so
that's where the respect comes from
it's like no matter what the inspiration
is no matter what the process is for how
you came to that
that what you created i respect that you
know whether it's
it was uh from drugs whether it's just
you know you just got a different uh
creative side in your brain whatever the
case is i respect that but
a lot of what's coming out right now
it's it's hard for me to really enjoy
because
one i don't understand what the [ __ ]
they're saying and like
i think for me lyrics is so important
just because i was an artist myself
and so like the writing aspect of it um
and two is
if they even wrote it right i mean did
they have ghost writers on it did they
have
did they have other writers on it right
sometimes you look at
you know the sheet and there's like
seven eight credited writers right
and then so it's like if you're not
writing your own music
then what essentially where does the
artistry come from then
are are we essentially saying your voice
is your artistry like that
that's that's your artist's integrity
right there and i
i can't [ __ ] with that like you in order
to be an artist you have to be really
creating
and it's like i'm not saying you can't
collaborate with people obviously music
as a collaborative process is like one
of the most magical things in the world
right
yeah but then when yeah you got
like that many different writers on your
[ __ ] um
it's like how much did you really do
then you know and it's like
when you're in the studio and you're
doing these things
you can kind of get an idea when there's
that many writers
they didn't do that much yeah you know
what i mean uh most of it was
coming from yeah the some of these uh
just trying to grab points that's why
yeah they say a couple of words like yo
why don't you just take that hook yeah
and then bring it up like two spots
earlier and then use the word
the yeah make sure you give me my points
real quick
right yeah i want five percent for that
[ __ ] change because i feel like
that's even how it is with uh like
bigger artists
i forgot who was telling me this but um
he was telling me like even artists like
beyonce like you you see the album and
you see that she's credited as one of
the writers yeah but
he's like but she didn't really do much
like she walked in and she was like oh i
probably prefer to sing this spot here
and then she gets [ __ ] big writing
points because
obviously it's her album and his [ __ ]
beyonce yeah but did she really write
the song yeah
no yeah exactly that's that's the thing
and it's like
you know not to say that some of these
big artists aren't talented or whatever
and maybe they're at a point in their
career where it's like i'm too famous
i'm too rich to be inconvenienced by
anything you know so it's like i want
everything done for me
and then i'm just gonna come in and do
what i gotta do right
um but then there are still people who
really treat the process
like it's art you know and i respect
that and like
guys again going back to a guy like
kanye i know he's become a very
or even a more controversial uh figure
he's so polarizing
yeah he is he's very polarizing [ __ ]
yeah but
the dude is i mean he's a [ __ ]
creative guy you know
i'm sure his you gonna vote for him as a
president
i said he's a creative guy i didn't say
he's a political guy
you know that [ __ ] came out of nowhere
he's like i'm going to i'm
he's like yay for president yeah and uh
what what do people think people think
people are thinking that he's doing that
because he's trying to uh uh split up
the democratic vote right right
i don't i don't know if that's his uh
motive i i really don't know
i mean you can never guess with that guy
because sometimes it's just i don't get
him yeah he goes on a bender sometimes
you know
and i i think it's because he's bipolar
too sometimes
when he's up on his upswing he he might
just like kind of
go ham on on like crazy [ __ ] and then
sometimes he's on his downstairs did you
hear about that theory
about kanye west what theory how you
know this whole time he was wearing the
maga hat
and whatever and that that was what he
had to do to get close to donald trump
so he could do prison reform so this was
something that he
planned out since the beginning and
there was this whole tweet about how
um the money that he that people thought
he was donating to trump's campaign yeah
they looked at the receipts and it was
actually to hillary
but he was just doing this as a whole
like anime master plan
to just get close to the enemy and he
was just going to be a martyr and take
all these bullets
just so he could get justice done wow if
that's the truth man
i mean [ __ ] that's that that's pretty
crazy i hope
if i'll listen i haven't listened to his
music in so [ __ ] long because of his
[ __ ] psychotic episodes so i'm like
i don't know if i could [ __ ] with them
like that right he's still listening to
r kelly yeah
i'm [ __ ] around hot dog oh
dude that was hard you know what art
kell when the r kelly documentary came
out yeah you know the weird thing was
like i didn't know
this podcast is brought to you by
skillshare my friends are you that type
of person that wants to start exploring
a passion but you don't think you have
the time
or maybe you just don't know where to
start that's where skillshare comes in
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes to help you explore new skills
and learn [ __ ] on your own time and
schedule there are so many things that i
want to do and learn and skillshare has
the craziest amount of online classes
that i can choose from that i personally
love
right now i'm going through a course
called filmmaking from home and the tips
that i've gotten from this course
i use in my videos now you guys have
seen my youtube videos well
a lot of this filmmaking stuff that i've
actually picked up that i didn't learn
just from watching other people's stuff
i found it through these courses so
explore your creativity and get two free
months of
premium membership at
skillshare.combrain that's two whole
months of unlimited access to thousands
of classes for free
get started and join today by heading to
skillshare.com brain
that's two free months of unlimited
access to thousands of classes at
skillshare.com
brain it's like i knew of it yeah but
for some reason i didn't know
uh-huh you know because all the stuff
that he did for some reason i guess
because we were so young we kind of
ignored it yeah
i don't know what it is but uh when i
was thinking about my
uh wedding playlist there was like
[ __ ] four r kelly songs on there
and that [ __ ] had to be deleted with the
quickness
out of here well i mean i think it's
when we were younger
we didn't uh consume and receive
information on the level that we do
today you know so like
if the scandal breaks out there's only
room for one scandal yeah not like
five [ __ ] scandals at one time and
that's just in the first hour yeah
so i mean the way information spreads is
so much different now and
it's like like that and then everybody's
on it and it's trending on twitter
elon musk is endorsing kanye west
well elon musk and also uh obviously
chance the rapper yeah which i
i don't i i'm trying to figure out why a
chance but
they're both from chicago you know and
like when chance was coming up
kanye you know definitely like came out
yeah yeah
you know gave him a little bit of a
platform to get his name out there
um so that's probably why but does he
really think that kanye's going to do a
good job i mean he's clinically bipolar
he's
he's admitted it that's that's the thing
that's the odd thing like i personally
don't think i don't give a [ __ ] how much
you help me
out i'm still going to go by my moral
compass yeah that's the thing too i i
feel like people
confuse sometimes they go well if we're
homies i if i [ __ ] with or if you [ __ ]
with me you got to support me 100
what if you're a [ __ ] rapist i'm
supposed to support your raping i don't
[ __ ] think so we're gonna have a side
conversation here why don't you babysit
my daughter yeah
yeah like where's your [ __ ] moral
compass like i [ __ ] with chance the
rapper but i thought it was very odd
that he would
endorse him in that type of way because
he was tweeting like i've uh was that
kanye west put out this tweet where
um it was something about his mom right
and he was like how can i not support
this brother who
you know who has this beautiful soul or
something to that line i'm paraphrasing
by the way
but i'm like i love my mom too i
shouldn't be [ __ ] what the [ __ ] does
that gotta do with him being the
president of the united states chance
what the [ __ ] are you talking about you
know the thing is too though
is that we obviously
know of his public persona and like all
all the kind of mishaps that he's had
right in the public eye oh yeah
yeah yeah but the thing is it's like
well because i have a little bit of
anecdote
to that because like i got a friend
who's uh
i won't say what industry he's in but
let's just say he's in entertainment and
he's worked with kanye directly
and he told me like how perceptive and
and how like uh
smart kanye is when it comes to like his
own public image
right and so they did something for
kanye
and kanye looked at it and then he just
kind of processed for
you know like 30 seconds or whatever and
then he's like yeah but don't you think
that it should be a little bit louder
because people look at me
and they think i'm this like super loud
super brash type of personality
and that type of thing that we're trying
to do won't necessarily fit with that
image so i think we should go bigger and
we should go even louder with it
and he said he was really taken aback by
that because of how
perceptive he is of what his public
image and public persona is
and then he's and the fact that he's
placed to that not saying oh
we should tone it down to like do a
little bit of a damage control type
thing
no he's like that's what people perceive
me as let's play to that
you know let's let's make it bigger
let's make it louder let's make it more
in your face
and so that's the thing is that we won't
ever know
who that uh who we know public kanye but
we don't know private kanye you know
maybe that man that's hard to say too
it's just
i find it so hard to believe that
somebody can
can do that and then be okay
because i i mean i always say i don't
give a [ __ ] but i give a little [ __ ]
you know i'm not out here i can't i got
a conscience
know i can't do all of this you know i
don't i don't know if
i mean maybe i mean i feel like he is
somewhat of a genius i mean he's
this man creates culture at the end of
the day if people if you can't give
kanye credit for anything you could give
him credit for creating culture i mean
the man
he's a musician a producer that
single-handedly
affected streetwear the way that he did
yeah you know what i mean yeah
like he's played a huge hand i mean
people can go and say like well he took
from this this and that
but he's the one that had a huge
platform and the and the waves that he
made with streetwear is unreal
yeah for sure um and the thing is it's
like the funniest [ __ ] is the whole dad
shoes
uh trend oh my god people hate it yeah
when that first started trending i was
like that's [ __ ] garbage and i still
to this day until this day but the
waverunners i did not like
but kanye was like he actually
said something about that so his his uh
thinking process around it was yeah so
like i saw some of these taste makers
starting to wear
these dad shoes and maybe they were
doing it kind of like more
tongue-in-cheek and it was supposed to
be
like a sarcastic or even you know like
parroting
what dads are like but he's like i'm a
literal person
i just took it literally so i saw the
taste makers were in it and i
literally said that must be what's
popular so i'm gonna start [ __ ] with
that shoes
that's so [ __ ] funny and then he made
it this worldwide trend you know
that's so crazy it's it's that kind of
reminds me of when i watch some of these
uh people who break down films right
so they i forgot what this youtube
channel is people probably know this
[ __ ] but
uh they they break down certain films
and they kind of
break it down in a digestible form for
somebody like us who we don't really
know a lot of firm
film uh terminology and how these
directors come out with the with the
composition of their shots
and they're super intricate right they
draw these lines they say that you could
tell by the way this light is here is to
shape this area
to basically exact this type of emotion
and then i remember i saw this other
video where there was a filmmaker
and i can't remember who this is
somebody could look this up for me but i
was dying laughing because
this guy broke down why
this film was this way right and they
this person edited another clip or
somebody asked them about the
composition of a
particular shot and he goes i just use
the lens i thought it looked good
that's always the funniest [ __ ] it's
like that yeah like people kind of
sometimes over analyze it
you add a lot of this hoity-toity stain
to it sometimes people just have a good
eye for art
and that is what it is yeah because they
were breaking down why this uh director
specifically used like a 35 or a 50
millimeter lens
and why he chose that focal length and
he was just like i put it on i thought
it looked good yeah
that's it that's it yeah that's simple
sometimes i mean that's the thing man is
that
whenever you try to look too deep into
something you'll find dots to connect
you know what i mean
and that's where like those conspiracy
theories and all that should come from
uh but sometimes it's just like yeah you
got to take it at face value man there's
not always a deeper meaning
i'll tell you this [ __ ] funny story
too about brian mcknight so brian
mcknight first of all i'm a huge brian
mcknight fan
uh the way that i sing all my runs
everything else is based off of this man
yeah i idolize this guy right so uh
brian mcknight
he a friend of mine did a photo shoot
she's a photographer and then she told
me something it was a little devastating
but everybody knows that song [ __ ]
six eight twelve like well you like a
dream come true
everybody loves that song and it's
talking about these these
numerical steps to how he fell in love
with somebody right
and this fool told her she asked him
kind of how he came up with that song
it didn't go into the into the the
expose of the piece yeah
but she told me that he told her that he
came up with that
while he was taking a [ __ ] and he was
looking at an ikea pamphlet about how to
build a table
and so that's how he developed that song
i'm not sure it was ikea but it was some
type of furniture [ __ ] yeah
and that's and that's how he came up
with six eight twelve hey man
whatever the creative process like i
said whatever the creative process is
whatever it took to create a masterpiece
i ain't mad at it i feel devastating
though
because i love this song he was i
remember i feel like i know a majority
of the r
b music that i went for based on the the
romantic relationships that i
tried to have growing up just
specifically me just getting dumped or
rejected
so that's why i know so when i when i
was uh was how old was i 19 or 20 19 or
20 i was like dumped by my very first
girlfriend yeah right
from that point on i could recite almost
every voice to men
bribe midnight you were in your feelings
i could remember exactly how it was i
remember i made this mixtape for my own
heartbreak
and then i just hit that cd player
i made a mistake for myself and i laid
in bed and i remember crying so much
that the tears were going into my ears
dude
and i couldn't hear because i kept
crying into my ear holes
that's one of the saddest [ __ ] i'll give
a [ __ ]
i was devastated and that's why i knew
all these like obscure boys
songs that weren't radio hits is because
i had their [ __ ] on repeat
yeah and that was back in the day when
we used to download our [ __ ] through
bittorrent
yeah yeah before the spotify and all
these streaming content we had to
download that [ __ ]
and every song that i had to download by
the way you [ __ ] was like
one track was three hours to get because
i had like 56k
so they should so you have to understand
how much i love
that music to take three weeks to have
one mixtape
and i cried my ass off
[ __ ] that [ __ ] i [ __ ] loved you hope
i [ __ ] loved you how long was the
relationship like a year
oh okay that's still hey for for high
school she was she was like my very
first girlfriend
i mentioned her so many times and it's
funny because i haven't been into
after her i didn't get into a lot of
serious relationships because i was so
dedicated into one person i kind of
realized how close-minded i was yeah
specifically for somebody who wanted to
be a stand-up comic and who wanted to
have life experiences
i kind of chose to be this i would say a
one
woman man like as if um i was like
polyamorous or anything like that but
more in the sense of
i all i wanted for myself was like the
the white picket fence a house and to be
married to this one girl
and i wanted to be a staff at 18 years
18. but i'm from sacramento we were a
small town yeah you know so
and i was like how the [ __ ] are you
going to do this and be a stand-up comic
i didn't really think about that i just
thought about her yeah
and then you're like romanticizing this
like picture book doc i remember this
one point because she and i were
after i broke up we were still kind of
like on this weird like friendship thing
i remember i told her i was like [ __ ]
and i had this moment where i'm like i
can't be in sacramento
anymore and i looked at it i was like
i'm gonna just [ __ ] buy a one bus
ticket to la and never come back
and she looked at me like i was the
dumbest [ __ ] person on that she goes
why a bus ticket i'm like
[ __ ] because i'm broke dude that's why
a bus ticket [ __ ] questioned me
because that's what you do when you're
[ __ ] sad and heartbroken
you take a [ __ ] grace right and you
buy a [ __ ]
40 and you're drunk i was like you did
this to me what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
and i think i would just say that [ __ ]
too or just elicit a reaction out of her
as a young person
because i wanted almost her to feel bad
it's like [ __ ] you're the reason why i
know all these bride midnight songs so
because of you you [ __ ] man when
you're 18 19 years old man
you gotta be thinking about [ __ ]
skittles taste the rainbow you
got experience i wanted to get married i
wanted to have kids i actually wanted to
be a teacher
right right which is weird like i when i
look back at this timeline i'm trying to
figure out
when these thoughts happen right because
i wanted to be a teacher i remember i
wanted to be a stand-up comic
and i started doing stand-up when i was
16. so
somewhere in between me still wanting to
be a stand-up comedian i also wanted to
be a teacher but how the [ __ ] was that
gonna work out i know all these things
coexist
man i mean the
i mean [ __ ] that would be a huge
accomplishment if you were able to
balance all of that yeah
i didn't really think out anything as a
kid i just wanted what i wanted at the
time
but that's the beauty of it though bro
that's the beauty of imagination that's
the beauty of like
being kind of naive right and and um
that that's why it's like you still have
that pureness somewhat you know and
that's why i
like love when kids are just able to to
kind of like be
free and and just kind of like express
themselves in the way they express
themselves
because seeing that it's like did i
remember that i remember
what it was like to not have
all these responsibilities and have all
these things that affect your
decision-making process
yeah because it kills it kills that that
inner child in you little by little
you know i feel like i'm gonna be the
parent that when my kid comes up and he
draws something stupid in front of me
i'ma [ __ ] tell him it's dumb what the
[ __ ] is this
i'm really going to do my best
i'm going to do my [ __ ] best when
they come up and they're like dad i got
this great idea yeah
i want to make these little spinach
bowls and then sell it to the other kids
and so i can make a lot of money yeah
and i think as an adult as a parent you
want to kind
uh i encourage you encourage them and
support this idea and say hey you know
what
that's a good idea i'm gonna help cook
that spinach for you and then we're
gonna sell it out in the street and just
go out there
i feel like that's what good parents
should do are you a [ __ ] idiot
i've been looking at me like are you
[ __ ] done
who the [ __ ] is gonna buy your spinach
where you popeye [ __ ]
throw that [ __ ] in the [ __ ] garbage
can and sell something real i mean
that's that's gonna be kind of the
challenge though right of being a parent
right because like
now you you have to take
what you've learned and kind of like
your life experience
and and like not necessarily apply it to
the kid at certain points in their life
yeah
explore yeah yeah this podcast is
brought to you by
me undies have you ever looked at a pair
of your underwear and wondered why you
chose to have this shred of sandpaper
covering your delicates you're asking
yourself these questions because you
don't own
a wonderful pair of meat undies the crap
you have on now is
hideous and you should be ashamed of
yourself well no more you sons of sexy
[ __ ] you deserve
better super fun prints amazing fabric
and it's just dope to have some boxers
i can feel sexy in and not only do they
have the best undies they got pajamas
tops bottoms that are thick and
comfortable as well
listen between you and me i usually
sleep butt naked but these are so
comfortable
i can feel butt naked without being butt
naked
that's a davidso guarantee me undies has
a great offer for my listeners for any
first-time purchasers you get 15
off and free shipping to get 15 off your
first order
free shipping a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee go to
meundies.com
brain that's meundies dot com slash
brain one more time to get this offer
that's me
undies dot com slash brain but that's
it might it might be a little bit hard
you know because uh
you might be having a bad day one day
and then you look at that you're like
the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] sometimes i'll
be looking at these kids
and they they kind of draw their [ __ ]
for their parents they're like look what
i did and the parents like that's the
best thing i've ever seen
yeah i mean you [ __ ] liar amy is
trash but yeah yeah no
to to be honest though to be honest like
when you see this like
existing being that came from your
[ __ ] balls
right and they're a living breathing
human being
that [ __ ] might it might be incredible
you know that like yeah when you see
i was like oh because you saw them from
conception
yeah yeah oh [ __ ] like i can't yeah like
they're actually [ __ ] doing something
now
so i can't understand that because i
don't have a kid so yeah i have no
clue what that feeling must be like but
i can kind of imagine
of thinking man like dave chappelle said
you were inside my balls man
yeah and and now you're this [ __ ]
human being who's
who's coloring outside the lines dude
dave chappelle's uh i thought it was a
stan it's not even a stand-up special
where he did the whole
where he just opened up that tent and
god knows where and he talked about the
whole george floyd situation
that [ __ ] was amazing that was that [ __ ]
made me laugh and that [ __ ] made me cry
i was like i'm [ __ ] tearing up yeah
yeah something about the way dave
chappelle speaks it
it kind of he does it with such
convictions right sure as fool said some
of the funniest [ __ ] but he says some of
the most poignant stuff too
and and it flips like that on a dime you
know he's like
leading into what you think is a joke
but then it doesn't go all the way there
and then he flips the script on you and
you're like oh [ __ ]
i wasn't ready for that but that was
[ __ ] powerful you know
i mean he's look man he he's he's a [ __ ]
he has the gift of gab man
he's like a master of speech and he like
master of timing
he just knows how to hit hit it right in
the pocket right in the fields
um and you know i i feel
thankful to have somebody like that
during my lifetime
just to provide that type of social
commentary who's also a comedian
right and and to you know just be able
to laugh at it and also
kind of give you more perspective on the
situation because the dude is a [ __ ]
intelligent guy man
yeah i i don't know why something about
the way he sets up jokes that i think
typically that
when most comics would tackle the way he
does uh
say i say sometimes insensitive things i
don't know how he does it in a way where
typically stuff that i probably would
find offensive i find it so funny yeah
i don't know how he does that [ __ ] i
think i think it's like um
he just knows how like he's he's
mastered the art of being real
you know what i mean like you what do
you think pc culture has gone too far
when it comes to comedy i think so
yeah i think so i mean because the thing
is
just in general not just comedy but just
just in general i think it's gone a
little bit too far with things like
people are so hyper sensitive to
everything you know
and it's like look man i understand that
it might be something that is near and
dear to your heart for whatever reason
but at the end of the day it's like dude
if we can't laugh at certain things then
what the [ __ ] is the point of living
like if we're so serious and uptight
about everything all the time
and those things exist to kind of
lighten it
not to necessarily like attack a certain
topic
or or to like uh you know be like i hate
a certain type of people
it's dude it's just all in in
good-natured fun
and and like again going back to dave
chappelle i think he's a master of that
like you can tell he's not a [ __ ]
hateful person there's no like malicious
yeah there isn't there isn't he's just
seriously like
making a joke about it and and if you
can't laugh at it
i feel sorry for you to tell you the
truth yeah because i i don't feel like
you really
uh taking advantage of what life has to
offer
you know because i think sometimes
people convolute where uh you know
because i do a lot of these
videos where i roast people right yeah
and like it's like literally 70
comedy 30 some serious thought right and
when it comes down to it
like i always use an example of people
like what if they make like jokes about
asian people i'm like let me tell you
something
if there was nuance to it and they're
kind of delving into like some type of
asian thought that i could relate yeah i
probably [ __ ] laugh
yeah i always use russell peters peters
for an example when russell peters did
that chinese accent
dude chinese people asian people we
cracked the [ __ ] up because of how
accurate and nuanced it was right dave
chappelle too he didn't understand it
where he did that
he was like hey i'm chinese and he was
talking about if he could
um choose whatever identity he could be
right so that's like the root of the
joke
uh i can laugh at that nuance right yeah
but when you're just attacking it
without making me laugh
that's where it becomes a little odd
right and there's also stuff too where
sometimes people like to
make examples of of these comedic jokes
without
giving context and also to without um
telling people how how it was presented
right because
nothing is ever black and white in that
type of sense specifically when it comes
to comedy i
i want comedy to be able to live and i
think sometimes people
or what i have been reading a lot is
like oh you comics think that you could
say whatever you want because it's a
joke
yeah not just us you too
yeah as long as the joke is perceived
well and is taken by the right crowd
if my thing is this if there was no
malicious intent and
sixty percent of the or seventy percent
of the room is laughing and there's
thirty percent that's offended
i i might be in that 30 crowd that's
offended by right right right
but i won't be shouting out you should
cancel this person yeah
right cancel this [ __ ] [ __ ]
person yeah and i think like kevin hart
always touched on it too where he thinks
cancel
culture when it comes to comedy is
absolutely ridiculous well [ __ ] again
cancel culture in general is pretty
ridiculous right now yeah you know
yeah there are people who have done some
pretty horrendous things harvey
weinstein being one of them
yeah canceling a guy like that
absolutely there is
nothing to disagree about on that it's
not even kansas he should be in jail
yeah yeah exactly yeah so so like things
like that
of course but because somebody made a
joke that hurt your feelings
yeah because even when it came to that
guy so remember that guy that was casted
in snl that dude shane gillis
yeah right yeah yeah you know i was like
irritated about what he said because
there wasn't any joke
and then he later on because i was just
doing a comedic bit i was like you
weren't doing a comedic bit
that was just your opinion about how
dirty you thought asian people were yeah
right and they're like he should be
canceled i don't know about that i think
he should still be able to work for snl
he's a comic
if he really thought that was a bit then
fine whatever um but
it's it's kind of odd how that power is
in people's hands to do that
yeah man and it's a simple thing it's
like if you don't find him funny from
here on out you don't support his ticket
sales
right right and here's the thing is that
do people are people not allotted uh
mistakes you know what i mean sometimes
you need to make that mistake
in order for you to reflect on it and
get better from it
you know sometimes yeah you might say
something that's misguided or
ignorant and then somebody calls you out
on it
and you know the hope from there is that
you're able to reflect on it like
be able to be honest with yourself not
get so defensive not put your shields up
be like
okay maybe there's a possibility here
that i [ __ ] up maybe
i gotta look into what it is that i'm
thinking and what it is that i said
or what it is that i did even and see
reevaluate this
and then learn from it but then if
you're talking about oh because this
person [ __ ] up you automatic we should
cancel this person
then you're essentially saying people
aren't allowed to make mistakes
sometimes people do stupid things
and especially when it's in the past
right and then you haven't seen these
type of behaviors reflected in who they
are now yeah
then i honestly what's the whole point
of digging something up that happened 10
years ago that isn't a reflection
of the person that you see before you
yeah the content that they create right
so i'll give a great example so
i have a couple friends of mine um they
did this video
um they basically played this game
and it's it's terrible not even in
hindsight what they did it was pretty
bad right
and so they were drawing this
uh it was this this is what the game is
let me just preface that
so the game was you have a hat and
inside this hat
are a bunch of people that is it is
impossible to make fun of
right that is the whole stick of the
game okay and so
they had a lot of people and they had
like jesus whatever the dalai lama
whoever you can
one of the names that was in that hat
was uh trayvon martin okay
uh it got drawn and the person who made
that joke yeah wasn't my friends
it was the other this was shane dawson
he's under a fire for a lot of things
we'll talk about that another time
and he made a joke about trayvon martin
the kid who was murdered
and he said um uh maybe you wouldn't
have gotten murdered if you had a job
and it's like what the [ __ ]
you know like what the [ __ ] were you
thinking right
but they got burned because they they
kind of they laughed at the joke
it doesn't help that they're white yeah
yeah you know what i'm saying
and so they put out a public apology
video and you guys know who they are
they're stephen nicky so steven nicky
put out a public apology video
the first one that they did wasn't that
great um i don't think they awarded it
very well i think they got scared
and so they wanted to put out a quick
apology video but they did a second one
which was a lot better and they
apologized for it yeah they apologized
what
what how it hurt the community
specifically in these times right now
and a lot of people are asking me it's
like well you're doing these why don't
you roast them
i was like because they apologized yeah
they were quick about it right they
apologized they made these videos
and because they are my personal friends
do they get preferential treatment of
course they [ __ ] do we have a
personal [ __ ] relationship
yeah if before i even got to contact
them they already apologized
yeah exactly so what do i need to do
call them up and be like hey
you should apologize yeah they already
did yeah so they
they knew that they [ __ ] up yeah they
knew that it happened in the past and
they
and they already put that video down
prior before
um before the whole blm movement
happened they didn't take it down
because of blm they took it down
years ago because they looked back on it
they thought it was [ __ ] up yeah
but um there was a kid named jay versace
who i do follow this kid's [ __ ] funny
he put their stuff out and he put them
on blast and so
um they took that small clip and i think
like the original apology it was done
kind of too suddenly yeah so it kind of
came off as if they were
trying to make excuses for their
behavior but that really wasn't the case
and when they came out with the second
apology which is how they really felt
and they better warded it it showed
change
right and i i know them personally they
don't have like a hateful racist bone in
their [ __ ] body yeah and because i
have that personal relationship and i
haven't seen that from them
in the three four years that i've known
i can i can vouch for them and say that
yeah they still have to apologize which
they already did so what's the whole
point of me
taking the clip of the video and doing
an angry rant about them when
i can just talk to them yeah and that's
the biggest fundamental difference
though is that
you know some of these people that
you've roasted they get defensive and
actually double down sometimes yes they
do on what they said
they're not taking a moment to reflect
and being like oh [ __ ] maybe i did
something wrong or said something wrong
here
maybe i should you know uh reevaluate
and apologize
i mean some of these people are not
doing that so when you've taken
the moment to reflect on what it is that
you did
and you know everybody processes it
differently you could you could learn
about it
uh same day or you might need to take a
week or two weeks or whatever right
whatever the case is once you come to
the conclusion
i [ __ ] up here and since i did that
publicly i need to offer up
an apology publicly as well um
then yeah what is there to roast about
that yeah they already apologized yeah
and
look i could see the argument of oh you
know but they only did it because they
got attacked
again there are plenty of other people
who are getting attacked who will not
offer you an apology
who will double down on what they're
saying get defensive about what they're
saying and stick to their guns
you know yeah and i've like i said i
know them i've had personal
conversations with them
and their situation too are
i mean nikki she's like part filipino
and whatever right but that girl is
white as [ __ ] she's as white as it
[ __ ] gets
you know and you know the girl grew up
uh around
a majority of [ __ ] white people and
you know steve is as white as it gets
it doesn't help steve's case that he
looks like a kkk member too
i'm [ __ ] with you i love you but you
know
he looks like prototypically he could be
a racist if you take a look at him
but in their case i know them so yeah
they do get it passed because i could
just talk to them personally i don't
have to do a rant video i know them yeah
i can call them up and be like bro what
the [ __ ] were you thinking yeah
but then when i saw the video it was
from years ago and i know that they
already took that video down prior
before because they knew how dumb it was
yeah
they already learned from this i haven't
seen the reflection in that so these
people have grown from the situation
so what's the whole point of beating
somebody down
um and trying to correct the behavior
they've already corrected themselves
and and look that's that's what i'm
saying is like people
are one super hyper sensitive
um and two is they won't do their due
diligence as well because sometimes
it's like they'll you know some type
some something's going on an event or
whatever
and um you know i'll look at twitter as
one of the outlets for like
real-time news updates and then i'll see
certain things like maybe supplemental
evidence coming
out of a certain incident right of yeah
there's a behavior of this pattern
whatever
but sometimes that's just straight up
[ __ ] it's just straight up made up
you know
and people start thinking oh yeah that's
valid evidence because somebody tweeted
it and posted it out
you know it's like nah you gotta do your
due diligence too do they have a history
of this behavior
you know or or is this more like a
momentary lapse in judgment
is there is there is just a [ __ ] up
right and can they come back from this
yeah it's because a lot of some of y'all
[ __ ]
act like you're perfect if i look the
only difference between you and some of
these other people and i guarantee
you've probably done way more [ __ ] up
things than these people have and
haven't learned from that is that
they're in the public eye the public
figures for sure
you're no [ __ ] different and some of
you are 10 times [ __ ] worse like
there was a
i'll give the greatest example remember
that one girl who wore that chinese
dress
for her prom and the people were
flipping out about it saying it was
cultural appropriation
that this chinese dress isn't your
[ __ ] costume or whatever yeah
but this dude but this asian that
attacked her people found his tweets
and he was dropping the n bomb with the
hard r like [ __ ] who the [ __ ] do you
think you are you're talking about
cultural appropriation and being racist
you're ten times worse she just wore a
dress and she
looked good and the funny thing was in
that situation people in china were like
what's the problem she looked good
like she looked so good like what the
problem is they weren't tripping
yeah but this guy wanted to make a big
deal about it because for some reason
it bothered him when he's the wrong he's
the one going around saying racial
obscenities about another culture and
another race so
how are you any different so it makes me
wonder about people who are pointing
these fingers so [ __ ] hard
like what's what are the causes that
you're hiding yeah or the skeletons in
your closet that you're hiding yeah i
mean the thing
is is that sometimes uh
well that's the shame about technology
is that
you know it's enabled a lot of these
trolls and a lot of these keyboard
warriors to basically say whatever they
want to say without repercussion
um and kind of free
of guilt and having a conscience because
i guarantee you're not going to say that
[ __ ] to their face
yeah of course you would never say that
yeah you don't have the balls to do that
you know
i don't have the balls i think i [ __ ]
do that [ __ ] in my car
but but it makes it makes it so easy
makes it so easy to
to just you know put somebody on blast
like that and then
um to feel empowered by it once people
start uh kind of supporting
what it is that you're saying man i'll
put it to you like this man um
i know a lot of people might think i'm
being very hypocritical because i roast
people
but remember like i'm a comic first
thing is to make you laugh right and you
know sometimes
with comedy there's a little bit of
seriousness and that's why it hits a
little harder some of those videos
weren't comedy it was just my thoughts
yeah
but just to put in perspective one of
these one of these dudes
i forgot what his name was he was a
korean rapper and he was saying some
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
um specifically about the bl and he was
like i understand the campaign he goes
[ __ ] that [ __ ] you guys can't take
anything away from me
and he was going off and i even messaged
him i was like bro
if you full heartedly apologize and you
can sit there and reflect on it
i'll take this video down no problem
uh he put out this half-assed [ __ ]
apology i was like nah
right yeah cause i'm not i'm not telling
people to cancel him yeah
i'm just saying i was just more like
just calling him out calling you out for
it yeah you don't have to cancel them
you guys can support his music or
whatever whatnot that's up to you
just know what you're supporting know
what you're supporting and so in his
case i even messaged him i said you can
apolo if you apologize i'll take your
[ __ ] video down yeah and he did this
quick little half-ass thing and i'm like
nah it stays up
you know it stays up try again try to
try again
it's weird too when it comes and there
may be a time where somebody where i
have to apologize for something that i
said right and i say a lot of crashes
and sensitive things
very crass and insensitive and i might
have to do an apology man
yeah i mean that's that is kind of the
price that you pay
being in the public eye and i wonder
sometimes too if i have to take a stand
for comedy or if it's something where
it's just so
wrong then i'm going to have to
apologize for it it is what it is
you're like sometimes when i do this
podcast i'm like did i say something she
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
you know but i was like well i'm a comic
i'm making jokes you know yeah like
there's no malicious intent and it
should be
yeah if it's perceived fine it is if my
thing is like if ninety percent perceive
it fine and ten percent kind of a
defensive
you can suck my dick yeah that means
that i i did my due diligence
well i mean look man again i think it
it's like the overall picture
you know does this person have a
behavior of
like um being negative or like you know
being hateful
right or is it just a joke
you know um and i feel like that line
has become
such a gray area and yeah people think
it's crossing the line every time now
i know a lot of people who make like um
just a joke and it offends me
but sometimes i just let it slide
because i'm like this [ __ ] just
tried to make a joke and it didn't work
yeah you know like i can't be up in arms
about that [ __ ] because it makes
me into a hypocrite because i'm a comic
i say [ __ ] up [ __ ] all the time
i sometimes have to look at these people
and be like you got a [ __ ] up set
and just move on from it like i've like
for example there was a
i was at the post office and this dude
was trying to relate to me in some kind
of way this was
pre-covered this was like a few years
back okay but he was like
you could tell like he was trying to
make like funny asian jokes because he
had a couple of asian friends yeah
i don't know this [ __ ] so
clearly i'm gonna find it offensive yeah
you know but he was making like some
like korean korean jokes i forgot what
it was but that's something to do with
like kimchi and how it smells or some
[ __ ] i knew it
right some [ __ ] like that right yeah i
just kind of just looked at him and like
smiled and i had to really think at that
moment it's like
he's actually trying to be nice yeah you
know he's actually not trying to be
offensive and he's trying to make jokes
and make me laugh
it's not working but i'm not going to
get into his face
have a side conversation with this guy
and be like [ __ ] you guys yeah like you
need to cut that [ __ ] out yeah
because for me i saw his intent he was
trying to relate and i could i could
tell he has korean friends because he
wouldn't know these things unless he
knew something about korean people
so i'm just like whatever let it go it's
a bad set yeah
you know you tried you shot your shot
but
oh man all i did was like haha okay man
that's cool that's cool
yeah you know
you know sometimes too though people are
kind of socially awkward
or just just not very socially adept you
know
um doug man i i run into those
situations all these times where
sometimes these people who
they're not really fans they kind of
know of me in a peripheral sense
but they they they try to act super cool
and i
like i don't give a [ __ ] if you know me
or not i don't care like
why do you have to [ __ ] puff your
chest so hard so i was at a
kangaroo peck jump right there yeah okay
bbq spot yeah bomb ass place man shout
out to kangadong
so um give them a sponsor let me eat
there for free
but uh i was there and this guy you know
he's he's serving our table
and he looks at me and he goes um he
goes like oh you look kind of familiar
which that means you already know who
the [ __ ] yeah
you already know who the [ __ ] i am yeah
right have a very distinct cookie face
he goes you kind of look familiar like
do i know you from somewhere i'm like i
was like nah probably not yeah you know
because
just you saying that already kind of
already irritated yeah yeah right
because i have to do this whole song and
dance over and over and over and i
understand like maybe some people are
awkward so i
i don't get mad about it it's just kind
of like i have to do this so many times
and i'm like uh probably not right and
then i'm just trying to eat and chill
and he goes oh okay he goes
i do know you man he's like you're uh
he's like you're you're on youtube and
stuff i was like thanks man he goes yeah
he's like i used to watch your stuff
like
back in the day and i'm like cool thanks
man and i'm trying to eat yeah
i appreciate it and then he comes back
and he leaves and i think he's trying to
be funny or something and i'm sitting
there and as
as we're eating he he looks at me and he
goes like he goes he goes oh is that
your bag
because it's kind of like a female-like
bag it's kind of girly for a big dude
like you
and i look at him and i remember i
forgot who was next to me
but i remember exactly what i said i
looked at him i said you're bombing
yeah because i what i was like you're
[ __ ] bombing nobody's laughing
i was like if that's the set that you're
working on you're bombing
get the [ __ ] away from me and bring me
your manager yeah right and i came back
and he because it was like he was trying
to make a joke at my expense yeah you
know he was like trying to make the
the group laugh at the table at me and
i'm like bro if you just did that to me
whatever but now you're now you're
trying to be mr cool guy
like you're trying to be the guy that
roasts the guy that roasts other people
yeah and so you sit there and the whole
table's laughing at him he's super
embarrassed yeah you know
because he goes oh i didn't know you
were sensitive i was like nope come back
i'm like
i'm not sensitive i'm sitting here i
don't know you and you're making this
very awkward it's like why
do you want to make this awkward yeah
it's like just just be nice
i'm just trying to eat my meal yeah i'm
just trying to eat man i was like you
want to talk to me after don't make this
whole scene in front of my friends
just go away yeah the manager came out
how to apologize to me
and then afterwards i came up to him too
i didn't leave it at that i was like hey
bro like no i'm not trying to get you in
trouble or something but you know that
that was
kind of [ __ ] up what you were trying
to do yeah he's like oh my bad man i
apologize he was like
he's just like trying to say sorry i'm
like it's like i'm not mad
it's just more like you're irritated i
was irritated yeah because you're trying
to make fun of me at my expense in front
of my friends yeah because you're trying
to be mr cool guy yeah cut that [ __ ] out
if you wanted to talk to me about stuff
we could have talked
time in place bro nice dude yeah
it's like and and the thing is uh you're
supposed to be a server
like yeah he's like you're still
supposed to do your job yeah i think
that was the thing annoying me the most
yeah get me my phone yeah like what
server is gonna come here and try to you
know clown on you
yeah like if if
like let's say the context was different
of this was just
a regular uh group of people and a
regular server
and the server decided to try to roast
one of those people yeah how do you
think that's gonna go for
example and i was like why did you think
my group of friends were going to sit
there
and allow you to do that yeah and there
was one dude that was going to slap the
[ __ ] out of him
and i was like bro what are you doing
kid
you know like and my friends too these
are like oh i remember my homies from
sacramento
and they just were like irritated
because they're not used to this type of
stuff yeah right and they're like is
this why people talk to you all the time
yeah and i'm like
how was he um
i don't know he had to be in his mid-20s
though that's pretty bad yeah he's in
his mid-20s he's out of college for sure
like he didn't look that young if he's
like a 14 15 year old
whatever yeah but he was an adult yeah
and so you know my friends are [ __ ]
irritated because they're not used to
this [ __ ] yeah i'm not personally used
to it either yeah so
because i feel like 99 of the people
they they just come up and say hi and
that's it right
we'll even have like long deep
conversations if i really click with
them
and it's great and people can attest to
that because that approach was really
odd
no i that that was honestly a big
lapse in judgment and and like to be
fair
i can see like let's say he was an like
actual fan of yours
like like a current fan you know and
maybe he was just trying to downplay how
much of a fan he is
yeah uh by saying oh where do i know you
from that type of [ __ ]
and so like the approach to that of kind
of trying to offset
and mask you know like him his
excitement might come
some people for some people might come
in out in a very awkward way you know
and i understand like the awkwardness
too because that's the stuff that i'm
cool with yeah right like
i get awkward too when i see somebody
that i like
right but then it's just the when he
came in hard and trying to make these
jokes it was like
what are you doing yeah like just say hi
like just say hi be normal around me you
know or just talk to me after or talk to
me after or something but you trying to
do a stand-up set every time you came
back from the table
and it's at my expense anybody would
take that offensively not just me just
anybody else
for sure it's just look man you don't
[ __ ] go to a restaurant for somebody
for the server to try to rush you know
i'm trying to eat my [ __ ] food yeah
there's a restaurant i think uh uh up in
the bay that does that or like seattle
or portland portland
yeah or or is it one of those places
yeah um but
you know it's like if you're not going
and paying for an experience like that
i just came here to eat and just to have
my food brought out to me
do you remember that one time where it
was like me you and z we were eating at
that breakfast place and
on sunset and there was that one weird
kid that sat at our table
uh we were eating at the spot first of
all i hate going to sunset i hate that
but it was his idea because he likes
bougie [ __ ] and so
man you don't remember that i remember
this [ __ ] because we were going to [ __ ]
this kid up because oh he got to that
point oh [ __ ] because we were we were
sitting at the table uh-huh
it was me you and z and we were having
uh brunch because it was like a waffle
or pancake spot
okay but this kid was also one of those
guys that we're trying to be mr cool
guys super funny
and as we're sitting there we're eating
he pulls up his chair and sits at our
table as we were eating you don't
remember this [ __ ]
i don't i remember the [ __ ] like this
yesterday so we were it was you me and z
we're sitting there and you know he
tries to throw a couple of jokes i don't
remember what the jokes were yeah but it
was getting to the point and i remember
you were the one that was irritated the
irritated first
and he just kept interrupting our
conversation and he kept on throwing
jokes didn't introduce himself he didn't
say anything so
wow really we didn't know who he was
yeah i was like i didn't think he was a
fan uh-huh
so he just kept on making these like
stupid jokes yeah and after a while we
were eating
and he pulls up his chair and he sits
next to us
and he starts and he brings his plate
and starts eating his food at our table
holy you don't remember this [ __ ] doug
and you got [ __ ] mad and which caused
me to get mad
right and then i literally walked over
to the next table i was like is this
your [ __ ] friend
you're like oh [ __ ] my bad we're so
sorry and i grabbed this chair
and i dragged him all the way to the
table i was like you eat here don't
[ __ ] come up to us i'm gonna [ __ ] you
up
holy [ __ ] man you were staring so hard
at it yeah and i got mad for you
holy [ __ ] man that was the worst
interaction i've ever had in that i mean
just hearing it is terrible
like i would be i would get irritated if
that happened you know
and he just started like he was so
[ __ ] rude to us i was like who the
[ __ ] is this guy and it turned out
he just he just knew me on youtube and
he was trying to make
make fun of me or some [ __ ] and then
after he saw all three it was [ __ ]
irritated yeah i was getting mad and i
don't think he really how big i was
you know he got super [ __ ] quiet and
just kept staring at him
until he got up and he left you know but
then his other friends apologized
they're like i'm so sorry i'm like yeah
was it was it an asian kid it was asian
kid trying to be [ __ ] funny dude i
can't remember this man
but no for sure if that happened i would
get [ __ ] irritated you remember that
one girl when we went to hodorie and she
was throwing ice at us
no damn your memory sucks doc you got
hella
mad so we were at so there's a spot up
in cape town called hodori
and uh that's the spot so me and edric
used to be insomniacs he still is
yeah yeah yeah but uh we used to so
that's like the late night spot after we
would go drinking kicking it or whatever
and when i lived in cape town i lived
there for about six years
and drinking and eating was our thing
yeah uh we were at hotori
and there was a girl that was uh saying
like oh i know who you are you're that
one [ __ ] funny guy
she's like make a joke say something
funny and then you in defense of me turn
around it's like hey we're trying to eat
yeah you know could you mind yourself
oh i remember that i do remember that i
do remember that yes
i do remember and then she got [ __ ]
mad and as we're talking she started
chucking ice cubes at you
remember that [ __ ] and then i was
getting
[ __ ] pissed yeah and then i just
remember
uh i was looking at her and then we were
saying some [ __ ] and i think the thing
that got them scared is because she was
with one boyfriend there's like four or
five of us at the table yeah
i just remember saying this [ __ ] i was
like hey nobody's gonna [ __ ] slap you
but we'll beat the [ __ ] out of your
[ __ ] boyfriend
right the dude was telling her to go for
the [ __ ] yeah
it's like yo chill chill chill there's
like five of us i was like wanna [ __ ] up
your boyfriend
i do remember that i do because uh i
remember she was uh
pretty drunk yeah you know and um yeah
she was to the back of me yeah and i was
like dude this [ __ ] is starting to
irritate the [ __ ] out of me right now
yeah it's like what what is she
because she was slurring her speech too
yeah i thought that's like one of the
most annoying [ __ ] to me man yeah
i do remember that incident um but the
other one i don't remember that
uh and i'm surprised i i don't remember
like something that ridiculous
that guy was being so [ __ ] ridiculous
man like he pulled up his chair sat
there
who does that i don't know [ __ ] does
he didn't introduce himself or
anything he did that would be
inappropriate right let me just join
y'all real quick yeah
because i recognize him i can't remember
exactly what he was saying but it was
something stupid
i was like oh what y'all eating blah
blah he goes this shit's really good he
starts like
munching in front of our face and stuff
and i'm like
does he know me or is he trying to be
funny he was like one of your friends or
something
oh my god you could tell when the mood
is getting really bad yeah people could
sense like oh somebody's about to get
socked
right and that's what thank god his
friends were there and they apologized
or whatever
because i was like doc i'm just gonna
start i'm gonna take this chair and
smash it over this motherfucker's head
this is about to become wwe right yeah
you know
i'm like you're about to get beat by a
really fat korean guy right dude
but you know that's the thing man some
people just are not perceptive at all
they just they don't have like the they
can't pick up on social cues they don't
know how to engage people socially
and and as a result it comes across as
very offensive um but
it's like it's hard man for somebody in
your position because you're recognized
like people know you and then there's
kind of that sense of
oh i know this guy because i've seen him
so many times on youtube or whatever
and there's a sense of familiarity but
then for you you have no [ __ ] clue
who these people are yeah
it's not like you don't appreciate their
support or anything but
it's like and a lot of people who can
attest when they
when they meet me i'm all about i talk
to anybody dude i've seen it i've seen
it
with everybody talk about deep [ __ ]
we're all good time in place though
yeah time and place and um like even
this last college show that i went to
i got a bunch of these stories man there
was one kid who for some
[ __ ] first of all 30 years old now
man
like i don't find a 19 year old girl
attractive ever
especially asian 19 yeah like you guys
look like you're 15.
yeah and so um you know i'm being super
friendly i'm joking around or whatever
and there was this one guy that was part
of this asian organization
and i could tell he really really liked
this one girl right but she was one of
the people that were showing me around
the college campus i'm like [ __ ] 11
years older than her dude
and i have a [ __ ] fiance
the [ __ ] you know and so we're joking
around you know i'm making people laugh
or whatever and i feel like that's a
part of my duty for these college people
that
take me out is not only they think it's
a it's their job to show me a good time
i actually think it's the opposite
i feel like it's my job to show you guys
a good time that i'm here to you know
kick it hang out or do whatever i'm here
in service for you guys because you guys
want me to come here and do this event
so why the [ __ ] not
and so um this dude was being super
weird towards me and super salty
and i just remember the girl was like
laughing because we were joking around
super sweet girl
and uh this dude kept on making snarky
comments to me
like about some stupid [ __ ] and the one
that really ticked me off was
uh she was like hey are you gonna come
out um to the after party and i was like
i was like honestly i usually don't but
you know if it's for you guys like i'll
be there i'll have a couple of drinks
and you know the guy you could tell when
somebody makes a joke when
it's made to uh be either an awkward
joke or it's made to
try to with malicious intent right right
and he made some kind of joke about me
being
really [ __ ] old or whatever right and
i looked at him i was like
she's not gonna [ __ ] you and it got
[ __ ] awkward his face turned bright
red i was like
she's not gonna [ __ ] you i don't know if
you haven't noticed she doesn't like you
yeah
right and then she started laughing
which didn't help him and then he got
super upset and you could tell he was
just in a bad mood
i was like bro you didn't have to do
that to me yeah i was like why did you
do that yeah you know i was like i'm not
hitting on her
but because you try to make this and
when he made that joke the whole room
got silent you could tell the air got
really [ __ ]
cringy so i had to say something to kind
of break up this tension i was like
she's not gonna [ __ ] you yeah
just to let you know i was like she
doesn't like you you can't tell yeah
right
and then the kid got really awkward and
i had to take him aside and have a
conversation with them
and i was like hey man i don't like
doing this [ __ ] i was like if you got a
problem with me say something because i
don't have a problem with you man it's
like i was just making a joke i was like
nah you weren't making a joke man yeah i
was like you think that i'm hitting on
this [ __ ] 19 year old girl
i was like if you like her just you know
you're gonna have an after party like
hit on her then yeah
she's just showing me around yeah you
know and it's weird i have to and i'm
talking to him like i'm his older uncle
yeah it's like
well technically you kind of are like
yeah uncle it's like
what is going on this is not a
competition i was like bro
i'm 30. yeah you know and you apologize
after he's like i'm sorry man it's like
i'm just like [ __ ] stressed out
because the show's over or whatever
it's like bro but you know you made it
really weird for everybody honestly you
probably apologized
because the whole room got silent
everybody kind of got really weirded out
and people are gonna remember that [ __ ]
yeah sometimes man people go out on the
limb to do something
and they quickly real instant regret you
know it's an instant regret like uh
i shouldn't have done that yeah um i'm
saying this is like this happens
very few and far between yeah yeah yeah
span of 10 years i have like maybe like
i don't know 20 or 30 stories which
sounds like a lot but you know after you
travel and you do so many stand-up
comedy shows
it's going to happen where somebody
doesn't like you yeah and it's just
you know what i do yeah exactly yeah and
like
also too i think there's kind of the
expectation um
when somebody is like a public figure in
some sense that
that person's always on you know like
you're not they're not they're human
beings too man
yeah they're not gonna always be on
whatever they're known for whether
they're a comedian
actor you know musician whatever the
case is
and whatever you think their public
persona is and and maybe you
uh associate that with maybe their
private persona like that's how you
think they are
man sometimes people just don't want to
be bothered you know and
it's like and look that that that is
definitely something that comes with the
territory i understand that that is a
price that
you know people have to pay for that
type of um position that they're in
but it doesn't mean that they can't have
a negative reaction to it either
you know yeah especially when you're
when you're trying to be mean to me yeah
right right that's a whole different
thing like when you're trying to if
you're awkward or whatever then that's
fine yeah because i'm awkward too yeah
like i'm
i'm super awkward i have social anxiety
so i get it it's just when you try to
disrespect me it's like
yeah publicly i was like i'm socially
awkward but that [ __ ] goes away when i
get mad
yeah you know so let's [ __ ] do it guy
man well guys that wraps up this episode
of the jesus
podcast uh by the way when you hear
these stories this is not how it is most
of the time this is like this is like
these funny intricate stories
there's a million of these stories but
majority time people are really cool
yeah i mean dude i've been there with
you countless times when people come
up and as long as they're respectful as
long as they're picking a good time and
place for it
you have no problem obliging them most
of the time it's oh my god david so i'm
a big fan can i get a picture yeah sure
let's take a picture that's it you chop
it up for a minute or two and then off
on their way right you said
pat their butt get out of here get out
of here buddy
but then it's these uh you know pockets
of of
not the greatest interactions yeah and
sometimes i make mistakes too like i
remember some uh one uh i was
as this this is on ongoing joke
sometimes that i do i don't do it as
much now but there was uh something that
came up to me and he was like
hey david do you mind if i get a picture
i was like [ __ ] you
this kid was like he's devastated i'm so
sorry i was like
i'm just kidding i'm kidding right and
then he was like
shaking because he was so nervous and
then i said [ __ ] you to him yeah as a
joke oh
man you picked the wrong yeah so i make
that mistake too
yeah i apologize i was joking yeah of
course you think
sorry like it took me forever to come up
to you and you know when you told me
that like you scared me
i felt so bad he mustered up the courage
to come
up and i wrecked his ass but i was
kidding
obviously we took a photo but hey man i
love you dude
you know i'm just kidding i'm like [ __ ]
you
he's like forever shattered his police
saw me do that joke a couple times too
he goes bro you're [ __ ] up
like it's a joke i'm kidding we still
take the photo you know yeah i just tell
them you know i laugh after some
i say about 50 percent of the people get
it the other 50 get devastated but
yeah they're like oh my god my title
just told me [ __ ] it
yeah but edward where can they find you
uh you can find me at ed2
instagram secretsociety.com yeah that's
scrt
society.com yes sir and uh yeah
every thursday sundays is a genius brain
podcast we talked about a lot of random
[ __ ] today
just here to be with you on your daily
commute and uh we'll see y'all next time
hey and by the way guys if you guys want
me to make a late night radio
show let me know it's just gonna be him
making [ __ ] [ __ ]
it is that's noises gonna be this
disgusting all right i'll see y'all next
time all right shall peace
you